Hello and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
live. I am your host Rawkode.
Today we are gonna be taking a look
at Tremor.
It metrics,
logs, collection, pipeline, transformations, loads of really cool
things for it to look at today.
And it's written in Rust, which makes the
project even killer in my book. I'm always
excited to see new Rust projects taken the
limelight. So before we do that, I'm gonna
remember to do my housekeeping for today and
that means I'm gonna ask you all very
kindly. Please subscribe to the YouTube channel, click
that bell and get updates whenever new episodes
are coming.
They are regular weekly and loads of cool
projects for us to explore.
Also, have a discord channel where loads of
people come and chat about the technologies that
we cover as well as general Kubernetes and
cloud native topics.
And we have a monitor observability channel, which
would be a good fit for today's episode.
Also, I need to thank my employer and
want to thank them of course. They're awesome
and they allow me to spend my time
playing with random technologies that I find exciting
and show them to the world. So thank
you Equinix metal. Feel free to check out
the products. We have bare metal clouds. You
can get $50 in credit. That is roughly
one hundred hours of compute depending on which
instance you you choose. So enjoy.
Now we have a bit of a treat
today. I am not joined by one nor
two nor three
but four guests from the Tremor team.
Hello everyone.
Just wave in all directions.
So could we
start with a quick round of introductions then?
I guess we'll start in the top left
and work our way around anti clockwise finishing
back on me. Please introduce yourself. Tell us
who you are and a little bit more
if you wish.
Well, hello, everyone. I'm Heinz. Like the catch
up, no relations there. Just the same name.
I've I've I've done open source for, well,
two decades nearly.
Quite enjoy it. Really happy that we could
do this with Tremor too.
And yes, I'm working on Tremor. The this
thing we are talking about today, you'll hopefully
hear a bit more about it unless we
get sidetracked and spend time talking about cats.
It has happened before.
Yeah. I I really am glad that I
can have a blurry background today, which is
my my
achievement of the week.
Otherwise, yeah, let's pass it on. Anoop.
Okay. Hello, everyone. My name is Anu. I'm
a software engineer at Wayfair.com,
currently based in Boston. So this was my
first real job out of college. I've been
working with them for over seven years now,
and I've been in, like, various teams within
Wayfair. So Tremor is the latest one among
them. So, yeah, I I I like working
for Tremor with everyone here.
I guess it's over to me. I guess
I'm the cut harder on Tremor.
Heinz and I started about two and a
half years ago, and it went to open
source about a year ago.
But, generally, we just sit down, write code,
have fun, and try and break it so
that it doesn't break up for anyone else
in production. And now over to the youngest
and newest and freshest
member of the team, perhaps the funniest, Mathias.
Yeah. Hi. Welcome. Mathias here. I'm I'm the
newest addition. I'm
I'm the one who's doing all the silly
mistakes and bugs, and I'm trying to introduce
them into our code base. But those guys
always stop me. It's it's annoying. So yeah.
I
have I am actually also on the
language and the core team of the Pony
language,
and this is also, like, how I got
to know
those people and how I got this job
actually. And now I'm writing Rust, although I
want to write pony all the time. But
it's it's great fun. Yes. Thank you. Alright.
Thank you everyone.
Lots of different accents as well. We we're
all in different locations. I guess you're a
fully remote distributed super team. Is that the
best way to describe you?
We're all distributed
across Berlin except to Luke who is He's
distributed to Boston. For some strange reason.
Are not Ah, has an import.
Yeah.
We stole him from The UK.
Ah. He stole me from Ireland.
Yes.
Okay. So much theft.
Yep.
Awesome. I I I I I'm gonna have
to get a bell or something to keep
you all in check, but we'll we'll we'll
get through this. Good good luck. Good luck.
I know. I'm getting that feeling already.
Okay.
So we're taking a look at Tremor today.
It's it's Rett and Rust even though
one or a quarter of your team wants
to write Pony all the time.
How does Pony and Rust connect? What's what's
the connection there?
Or is it Yeah.
It's like the focus on
safe
on the safe runtime, like memory safety,
database freedom,
all this stuff, like but the approaches are
totally different. And
Rust has a much bigger community and
yeah.
Yeah. I am a fan of the pony
language. I have tried many times to write
more of it, but that's maybe a conversation
for another day. We definitely should do a
stream on pony. I'm gonna end the next
That means we have half of the pony
user base here, don't we?
That's harsh. No. That's not true. That's not
fair. We also have half of the Erlang
user base here to be fair. Right, brother?
That's us too. Okay. That is fair.
That is fair.
So I think what we've got is a
collection of people that like esoteric programming languages
and solving Yes. Cool and hard problems. And
I think that is a fantastic mix of
people to be doing a stream today. Awesome.
I only have tears in my eyes.
This is going well.
Alright. Tremor.
Someone tell me what it is, please. I
I I said at the start, it's metrics,
it's logs, it's transformations,
it's event processing. Let let's let's dive into
that. Much more and so much less.
Yeah. Believe we've some slides. Was that right?
Yes. We have some custom slides,
which were prepared over the last decade
with a lot of care and fifteen minutes
over lunch.
So Tremor.
Let let's go a bit into it. Let's
start with,
first,
the
big bang.
Tremor today is doing about 10,000,000,000 metrics
or events every minute here at Wayfair. That's,
by the way, where all of us work.
So they they effectively sponsor Tremor,
which is a nice number, isn't it? 10,000,000,000?
Might be a bit more by now, so
who knows? Those numbers keep going up. Quick
three things we are going to talk about
in the slides. What the heck is Tremor?
Why the hell is Tremor? And where are
we hiding if you ever want to use
Tremor?
And I'm pretty sure everyone will want to
use Tremor after today.
At least everyone that wants to use Tremor
will want to use Tremor after this day.
So quick, what the heck is Tremor? And
Tremor is very simple
because Tremor is a lot of things. We
talked already about metrics, about logs, about events.
But basically, Tremor is two things, three things,
two arrows and one cookie monster.
Tremor
is sources, so something where data comes from.
Tremor is a cookie monster, so something that
does something with cookies or events.
And Tremor is syncs, which is something where
data goes to.
And that is pretty configurable.
Quick
idea about when we are saying source, what
do we mean? We mean certain connectors, HTTP,
Kafka, TCP, UDP, and a host of other
ones and some encodings.
Some we support right now is JSON, YAML,
message pack, just strings, just binary data,
open telemetry
since, well, since tomorrow.
Since tomorrow? Is that a word? Can I
say that? I don't know. I'll say it.
Yes. You you can say it. Good. Since
tomorrow. Worries.
Wonderful.
So
open telemetry since tomorrow.
I like since tomorrow. I'll keep using that.
Pipelines,
which is once the data is in Tremor,
what happens to it? We we have a
whole programming
language called TremorScript,
which you all have to suffer through later
when poor Rawkode has to write it.
And and you can filter the data. You
can transform the data. You can sanitize the
data to give it a common theme and
common look. And you can pretty much build
all kind of logic in it that you
want, Like, data in, data out, do do
stuff with it. Usually
shown as a cookie monster in our presentations
where we don't get sued for using that
picture. I hope we don't get sued. I
hope you don't get in trouble for this
picture, by the way. If you do, I'm
sorry. It's not our fault. It's your stream.
It's your responsibility. Goodbye.
Syncs is the other part, and this is
kind of a mirror of the sources. We
have, again, the connectors, HTTP, Kafka, TCP, UDP,
and so on. There's a whole host of
them, And they are on the website with
documentation. I'm pretty sure we will go there
at one point in the future today. And
same as the codecs going in, we have
them going out. So it could be JSON,
YAML, message pack strings, binary,
or make up your own, really.
So
why all that stuff? Why all the work?
First thing is that Wayfair, there are
thousands of engineers doing doing their things. So
there are a lot of metrics and stuff.
So there are a lot of people, so
there needs to be a good way to
deal with all the small things.
So
that leads to a lot of data.
We we had last time, we looked at
the numbers about 10,000,000,000.
I suspect it's a bit more today.
Events per millet or 3,000,000,000 a day, 3,000,000,000,000
a day,
which for everyone counting to trillion a day
is
significantly much.
To to give it other shape than the
silly numbers, it's about 10 terabyte or one
hard disk if you buy a really big
one or 10 small ones. Two
years out of date, I think. So They
are two years out of double million.
Yeah.
So,
yes, you can you can multiply that with
x, and you choose x to get a
correct number where x is somewhere between zero
and infinity.
But it's a ballpark. It's probably not an
order of magnitude of.
Last
but not least, there really wasn't something out
there that solved
the issue
completely without having a lot of trade offs.
Because realistically, not everyone is at the scale,
and most people are really happy with simple
solutions that work for them, which makes perfect
sense.
And if you're not operating at tens of
terabytes a day on data, there is no
reason to invest the time, money, or effort
into building something that can handle that.
So, yeah, that's the why.
Last but not least, at as promised, we
won't take too much time with slides. Where
are we hiding? I hope it's if I
pluck our stuff here. There's TremorS, the website.
There is GitHub repository, which is also linked
on the website. There's a doc site, which
is also linked on the website.
And we have a Discord server. You're all
welcome to come by and say hi.
There is a link for it.
It's probably also worth going in where Tremor
started or why it started in detail. It
wasn't really built
with the the current
scripting or event processing or,
ETL in mind. It was built for a
very simple problem. When a network operation center,
is under capacity for volume when we hit
peak load, Bad things happen. Like, our network
operating center folk are seeing,
data that's delayed a minute or two minutes.
And as you know, in a large production
environment, if you're two minutes out of date,
well, you're you're putting out the wrong fire.
So Tremor was basically introduced to solve that
problem and introduce,
a form of load shedding and capacity planning
and management that worked in real time. So
that went to production in six weeks, and
we spent the past two years avoiding that
problem of just having fun.
Yes.
It worked well.
Alright. Awesome. Thank you for the the introduction
there. So I guess I've I've got a
couple of questions. I I don't know if
we covered this during previous conversations, but I
know I my previous life, I did a
lot of things in the monitoring and observability
space. In fact, I worked for Inflox Data,
if you're familiar with that company.
Yes. This feels a lot like Telegraph. Is
that a fair comparison?
It it is a subset.
So Tremor
can pretty much do what Telegraph does to
the most part,
but it is a generalized solution.
You can do it on metrics, like aggregate
stuff, sum them together, filter them, rewrite them,
but you also can do it on logs.
You also can do it on, well, pretty
much everything else you want. You have a
structured data in, structured data out approach with
a language to modify the data in the
middle.
So, for example, we're we're currently putting a
system in production at work that is in
the search domain.
As Tremor doesn't really care about the underlying
symbology or the underlying domain
of Endeavor,
pretty much anything that's semi structured or self
structured, in nature
can be processed through the system. And we're
now starting to get into binary data processing
and workloads as well.
So that keeps extending.
So although logging and metrics are the observability
domain was where we started building the engine,
it's always generalizing and becoming kinda more useful.
And that tends to
of pull us into other domains and directions
over time. Like, I think the search solution
is is very orchestration. It's workflow oriented. So
if you imagine Yeah. You have a messaging
system inbound and outbound,
you're trying to index and elementize
documents style information,
pump it into a bunch of downstream systems
that are indexing
for search,
like to power recommendations and engines and things
like this.
There is no messaging system that gives you
fully validated,
authenticated,
and cleansed data as a transactional messaging feed,
because it doesn't do those complex orchestrations of
multiple external systems. So Tremor is now being
used for that use case, and that will
likely move us down into the orchestration direction.
So,
very much logging and metrics was the start.
Who knows where the rabbit hole goes, looking
forward?
We do support in the influx line protocol
as one of our codecs.
So you can encode and decode
influx data in Tremor.
Okay. Cool. Very cool. Alright. Kim,
what are the typical deployment architectures for Tremor?
Do I run one of them inside of
a data center? Do I run them on
every node? Do I get a little bit
more creative with the paired container?
Like, how do you use it yourself?
It depends a lot on your use case,
as always. Right? That is that is the
blanket answer to every question. It depends on
your use case.
We I'll I'll I'll leave out the clustering
part for a moment because Anoop can tell
us a bit more about that in a
second, I think. He he's working on that
at the moment. But,
basically, today, Tremor is either run as a
sidecar in Kubernetes
or
as a dedicated server for high load
massive pipeline situations where you have a number
of servers and load balance over them.
Yeah. I'm a big fan of of that
approach, and it's something I I try to
encourage people to do with with Telegraph and
other tools as well is that you really
get to dictate their own quality of service
when you run the collection
right next to your application. And then you
can have very specific transformations and aggregations that
are happening at that layer. I think that's
a really, really cool approach to doing that.
So I'm excited for what Tremor can do.
Something that we've not mentioned, but I I
noticed on the website is that Tremor is
also a a cloud data foundation project. You
wanna Yes. Is that recent, or is I
just did I miss the announcement? September,
I think. September.
We were invited to join
we're enjoined.
We're outjoined, I think, is the term. And
joint, yes, as a CNCF sandbox project,
which is super exciting for us. Yeah. And
definitely going against the grain there, not writing
your cloud native application in Go. Oof. Yeah.
There's only we'll change the CNCF. Go is
going out. It's literally going out. Yeah. Go
going gone.
I think Tremor
and maybe Linkerd I did not mean that.
I think Tremor and Linkerd are probably the
only two that I'm familiar with. They're they're
leveraging Rust.
Oh, yeah. T I k v as well.
That's right. Definitely. That's cool.
Okay. One more question then. Let's just get
hands on. I I asked this about every
project that's written in Rust yet, but have
you compiled it for VASM and run it
in a browser?
The
answer is definitely not because we use CMD
accelerated JSON passing.
Probably, that quite
a bit of work when you're doing SIMD
accelerated JSON processing. We don't even get it
to run on ARM yet.
So
And is that the cause of UMD? Is
that the same issue? Yes. It's the same
so
Rust
on ARM has not yet caught up with
Rust on x 68. Most normal stuff you
can run perfectly fine. I want to prefix
it. It's not like Rust doesn't do ARM.
But if you go into really low level
SIMD stuff,
Rust doesn't yet fully support that. For example,
you'd use you need to use Nightly for
compiling it,
that means that every other week, everything breaks.
It's just not worth the effort.
Yeah. I don't know if that makes me
a good Rust developer or a terrible one,
but I've never installed the nightly tool chain.
And I just tried to avoid it as
much as possible. Both.
It makes you a terrible good Rust developer.
I'll take it. It makes you a happy
Rust developer with a stable environment to work
in and take pleasure out of your trouble.
Cool. Can we I mean, who feels comfortable
describing CMD? I can give my very naive
understanding of it. But I believe the idea
is that you have a single value and
a register and you can perform multiple operations
on it at a much
efficient or effective process. Is that correct?
Matthias just gave a talk on that.
Literally. Literally on Bobconf, what, two weeks ago?
Yes.
Of me. I don't, like, I don't count
time anymore. It's Yep.
Time is a complicated.
Just just a very quick yeah. It's single
instruction multiple data. That's what single stands for.
So you have basically, you have fat registers
in your CPU,
and you can put, like, a number of
integers, clothes, whatever inside there, or bytes or,
like, whatever primitive
CPU
data type
you have. And then you can just run
a
fat instruction in the same time usually as
you do on a single one. And,
like, as a curious fact, like, most like,
all the Intel CPUs, they want they run
their floating point operations on those registers.
So you have you're already using them, but
you're underusing them.
Yeah.
So most compilers optimize very heavily and and
transform your normal code into,
like, unload loops and stuff. And so you
get so you you get to use
SIMD, but
in in the SIMD adjacent project,
we explicitly use
SIMD instruction. It's it's a it's a, like,
a whole new channel of CPU instructions in
those systems. It's it's it's fun, but it's,
again, a repertoire. Yeah. Okay.
I mean, so I go, like, completely backwards
then.
Basically, my entire yeah.
That's cool because, you know, what the best
thing I always say about doing this is
that I get to have wicked smart people
like you all come on and just teach
me all this stuff. So that it's Well,
that's the same for us. Like, the Cindy
stuff credit goes to Le Meyer et al.
He invented this. We've just ported it. We
just we we basically, we're in the business
of stealing great ideas.
But we give credit. We try.
Yeah. It's criminal but in a good way.
Yeah. It's like Robin Hood.
Okay. We have a question from the audience
and then let's get hands on with this
and start playing with So
you're gonna ask him, could this be compared
to fluent bet with regards to logs and
events? And would it be a good match
for integration
with connecting with Fluent Bit? And then there's
a quick follow-up is like, or would it
be a competing system?
Does anyone wanna touch on the comparisons to
to Fluent Bit? That's a great question.
Unfortunately, we don't know a lot about fluent
bit, but we can probably go into the
question if we ignore the fluent bit bit.
So is it good for normalization?
That's literally exactly what it's used for in
production. So the bread and butter use case
in our logging and metrics environments, and it's
starting to appear in other domains in production
at work,
is,
for the normalization
for dimensionalizing
real time streaming data. And then based on
the classification of that data and the dimensions
to within which it was classified,
to make decisions on whether,
to send that data downstream.
So 99.999999999%
of the time, Tremor forwards all of the
data it receives downstream in production.
Every now and again, when our systems go
over capacity
or there's an issue when one of our
data centers are in the cloud,
we don't have the capacity that we normally
have or the systems are flooded. Whatever reason,
Tremor needs to throw away some information.
And we try and throw away the least
important data to the business
at any given point in time. And that's
a fairly simple algorithm to build and define
inside Tremor. So what it typically does in
a in the logging system, which is a,
fairly simple three tier architecture,
on all of the source systems, so when
our data center is that's in the in
on the hosts that are running application logic,
It might be picking up syslog information. It
might be picking up, data from,
journal d or or syscontrol or something like
that or syslog,
as a sidecar in the Kubernetes case, sends
it to a transformation system where it normalizes
it. For example, try and get 3,500
developers to agree on what they call their
environment.
Is it gonna be env or environment
in in their data? Are they go even
going to agree on on the data structures?
No. So we have a team of 20
very dedicated folk in Boston. They just normalize
all of these datasets,
in production
and have a fine grained understanding of our
capacity requirements
from the operational infrastructure perspective,
but also from the production business need perspective.
In an ecommerce environment, in a production environment,
that changes by hour of the day, day
of the week, and the season,
that we're in in the year.
So it's really, really good at this particular
task. It's essentially what it was designed for.
And it was also designed in an environment
where it was designed to be transparent to
the existing system and the surrounding architecture.
So Tremor is an interposer.
It's like a spy.
Most of the developers of Wayfair don't even
know it's there.
Yet, all of their messages,
all of their logs, and all of their
metrics pass through it.
But they never need to see it. They
don't need to touch it. But they go
through Elasticsearch.
Elasticsearch,
as a front end to a developer is
being served in the back end through multiple
layers of Tremor. Similar to our influx environments,
Tremor is actually feeding our Influx environments,
inside work rather than Telegraph. So so Tremor
takes on that role and effectively
becomes Telegraph
for the metrics environment or becomes Logstash
for the logging environment.
So it would probably work similarly to,
Fluent Bit, except it's really designed for that
large scale high throughput environment.
We don't know the specifics of Fluent Bit.
There are likely features in Fluent Bit that
Tremor does not have.
It's likely a good fit for whatever it's
currently being used. So if you don't need
Tremor, just take a few minutes.
Yeah. There there's one thing which is a
big difference between Tremor and most systems, including
Fluent Bit, is that we design Tremor as
less a configurable system than a programmable sys
programmable system. We have a deployment language, and
we have a scripting language. Well, with systems
like Fluentd or Logstash, you usually have a
very configuration and plugin driven system where you
chain up your plugins. Well, in Tremor, you
have a query language which lets you describe
a graph and a programming language which lets
you describe a logic, and they fold into
each other.
So you're not hopping between different languages, different
systems, different logics. You don't write a plugin
in git a git in Go and then
write a script in Lua. You have this
one system that fits together.
And operator friendliness was always a very, very
important thing. So you will you will well,
hopefully, you won't see it because if you
see it, you make a typo, and the
system will tell you. But we have hygienic
errors and all those kind of things, which
we really
are proud of.
I think that is one of the biggest
differences to other systems that do event processing.
Alright. Perfect. Okay. We we spoke a lot.
I think we need to we need to
do a Well, speaking is always fun, isn't
it?
Yeah. It can be, especially when I'm talking
to you for it. That's for sure. So
we've worked not to be bored.
We got a comment saying a sidecar on
every pod we require to retrieve logs from.
Yeah. That's my understanding. I think that's a
really cool pattern. So I
would recommend you check it out. And then
I don't know if you know this person
but Rawkode has said, hey awesome to see
the whole team.
Hey.
Okay. Let's play with Tremor. Yes. And we
have a treat.
So
we we looked at some of your stuff
and they're all really interesting.
And but we figured we are doing something
completely
Everyone is expecting we are doing lots today,
but we are not.
So so here's the idea. We happen to
boss or bot?
Did you say bot? Can you read minds?
So Tremor is event processing, so it can
do very much, including Discord bots.
And we happen to have a Discord bot
written in Tremor. So the idea is, and
you depends on how you're comfortable you are
with it. Either you invite the dev of
the spot into your server,
and you you play around with it there
and can add some stuff. Perhaps let some
of the users there figure out a feature
that is worth adding, or we invite you
to our development environment for that bot, you
can go bananas there.
The bot's not going to run on our
systems. It's going to be run on yours.
So whatever is more comfortable for you.
I like the idea of going bananas. I
guess maybe we'll use
your one, and I'll run it on my
side. Is that the preferred approach?
What whatever you like. You you the the
we just didn't want it to, like, steal
people from your server and be like, hey.
If you want to play with a bot,
come to the Tremor server.
We also don't want to be, hey. Install
the spot on your server. So we let
you pick which one you want. Well, let's
try it on yours. And if I like
it, then maybe I'll install on it. Okay.
Let's let's let's you're on our server.
So I'll I'll invite the Tremor dev bot
to our server so people can play around
there. And I will give you first
the link to the code where you have
the starting point.
I'll I'll send you to this no. Not
to Matthias.
Here you go.
That is a starting point.
I
will send you the secret key as well.
Please don't share this key on
YouTube.
That's that's the one part that probably shouldn't
be shared.
I'm
going to invite But please share the URL.
We might have multiple commits during the live
Yeah.
Would be hilarious and awesome.
Okay.
And let's throw the
nice little Tremor bot. So the Tremor bot's
the limit on this is going to be
it can only read and reply to messages.
Messages. We don't give this one admin privileges
because it's a playground system.
Read, rev. Yeah. Send. There we go.
And,
yes, I'm a human. Silly thing.
Authorized. We have a Tremor bot. We have
two Tremor bots now. There's Tremor bot and
Tremor dev bot.
We we have a few ideas what kind
of stuff you could add to that, but
we want you also to just come up
with your own, what you think would be
a cool feature in a bot.
Okay. So I just wanna make sure I
understand where we are right now because I'm
I'm already confused.
So you have added a new bot to
the Tremor
Discord channel. Yes. I have the code for
it in front of me now, which I'm
now sharing my screen. I believe you're going
to send me something secret, but I don't
think you've done that I
believe I did.
The the there's a secret
s s h hash y s s h.
Right. Right. Got it. Okay. Actually, that's like,
if you if you look at the setup
part here, there is put your secret key
in the file
because the bot needs to authenticate with the
Discord API.
And this is the secret key that authenticates
it.
For safety reasons, I will recycle this after
today, obviously.
But
for today, you can play with that as
much as you want. Okay.
Let's get started then. So do I need
to clone this repository?
Yes. Yes. Okay. That I am confident doing
mostly.
So,
get clone
Tremor bot.
And
we have here now do I need to
read the instructions or you're just gonna give
me?
You can you can read the instructions.
Alternatively,
I can read the instructions to you or
because he has this nice nice Irish accent.
I guess you just want me to copy
this example to dot YAML and then make
a little bit of a Also make in
it works by now.
Because we are old, we like make files.
I mean, I like just files but I
guess I'll settle for a make file. So
let's see what the source looks like.
Yeah. This is where I need to do
the secret thing. Right? Yes. It's like big
big letters. Please please enter the secret stuff
here.
No? Alright. I don't know them, but I'm
horrible with names. Someone else? They're they're just
a a punk rock band, but on one
of their earlier albums, they had they actually
had an intermission halfway through the album. Was
just a little tune. And I keep wanting
to use it on the stream, but then
I know YouTube were gonna ban me.
I actually tend to buy license
rates to it. But apparently that's a major
pain in the ass.
Okay. I have edit this file. So what
I'm not gonna do is open it. What
I will do is open it here so
we can just kinda see what this configuration
looks like. So
we just need to
insert this token which I've done. We've got
some intents. This is just permissions against Discord.
Yep. And we just have some sort of
internal reference to tell which type of configuration
this is.
Is nice and simple. Nothing magic.
We can move on. Is that right? We
want to kill this eventually so the YAML
will go away. That's the one part that
isn't fully that is configuration of language.
That's on our to do list, but for
now, yes, it's YAML.
So is that a Tremor configuration?
Yes. Right. Okay. That is part of it.
That sets up the you remember this source
arrow and the Cookie Monster?
This is the source arrow. It tells it
where data comes from. It's also the
sync arrow because we need to talk back
to disco. But that is like, here is
where data is happening. This is the connector
to the Two years ago, Tremor had a
lot of YAML and not a lot of
programming language. Now it has a lot of
programming languages. There's not not a lot left
of the YAML.
The YAML will continue to disappear
because it it it provides a horrible
developer
and operational experience.
We started to move towards much more structured,
programming because you get a better class of
error back to the user. For example, who
likes an error from, say, a logging system
implemented on the JVM
that gives you 99 lines of stock trace
for one, oh, you you forgot a comma.
You've also just, oh, you forgot a comma.
Did you mean to add a comma?
A comma would be nice here. And we
call that hygienic errors.
I think that's something about the Rust compiler
and and development experience that rubbed off on
us. Yep. And we robin hooded into the
project, so to speak. I'm pretty sure there
are rules when you're a CNCF project that
you're not allowed to say bad things about
YAML. I'm just I'm just saying you gotta
be careful there. Like, you you you Oh,
we love YAML and other people's products.
Right. Okay. So let's make fail. We have
run it, and then we can see kind
of what it's doing. Did I just run
did I just run make run now? Is
that is that all I understand? That will
start. Yes. Then you can Is it gonna
print anything to my terminal that we don't
want to see? Yeah. It will well, nothing
important. It will just print a few things
and be like, hey. Oh. Oh, yes.
I am a local driver. Yeah. Yes. Yeah.
Because, you know, this is you're sending me
secrets on Discord. I I unzipped a binary
from an a random person on the Internet
and installed it to machine. This is not
a good example of how to computer, by
the way. Just saying.
That should Well, could have used an environment.
It's nice in the world to see such
trust in an individual.
Okay. I think it's running. Yep. Oh. No.
No. No. No.
Ah.
We need to set the module path.
And we need to give you the modules.
This is this is the wonderful thing about
live demos. We have no idea what we
are doing.
So,
that would or someone wants to explain it
while I copy the files.
So Tremor has is now building a a
growing library of reusable
code,
and it also has a a set of
links into built in functions in the Tremor
runtime and Rust,
that we provide as intrinsics that so they
can be referenced
in the interpreted code.
Binary that Hunt sent you, we omitted
all of that good stuff. I believe he's
probably sending you one now. I'm I literally
send it right now. So so this is
not a problem on Linux where we have
packages or on the
docker image because that's included.
We are not quite there on linen on
OSX.
K. So I I need to unzip this
here. Do I need to unzip it somewhere
else?
Here. Just here. And
it's all Tremor files, so there's the viruses
in there are all written in Tremor script.
So we want to now set a Tremor
pass in the environment. So Tremor on the
environment. Makefile takes
care of that. But yeah. Generally, yes. Okay.
Awesome.
There you go. Tremor's running. Invalid authentication.
Please check the token.
Did I break it?
Shouldn't have.
I I I would say let's look at
the token, but also let's not look at
the token.
Let me Let's think about the token and
guess what state I might be in. Oh,
yes. Because I'm the no. This is this
is me being an idiot. Okay. I don't
discard often enough. I gave you the public
key, not the secret key. Well, nobody wants
the public key. Yes. Well,
it it was easier to copy. There's a
big big public key button and I copy
It was shorter was the logic at the
time. It was actually longer, but I couldn't
see the secret one. It was hidden because
it's a secret. Oh, it failed again.
That shouldn't.
What does it say? Invalid authentication.
Was it a good one?
Let me just
Double check. Yes. That's the one.
Yeah. I think I copy and pasted that.
Okay. My copy and pasting is is not
flawless, but it's decent.
Yep. That perhaps my copy and pasting is
off.
Oh, yes. No. It's not. They they do
there are three different things. Uh-huh.
Is the secret thing, then there's a token,
then there is the other secret. Yeah. Let's
try the secret secret thing. Let's let's try
the next secret thing. There there are a
lot of stuffs to copy. I probably should
have read the read me we wrote about
how to get this data. Sometimes it helps.
Can you send me your date of birth,
your mother's maiden name, and your first school
please as well while we're at Actually,
I'll I'll just send you the configuration I
tested
Okay. It looks like it's working though anyway.
Yes. Perfect.
We've injected the third secret. We've got what
appears to be a working
Tremor. Secret. Yes. A working secret.
Okay.
So on our Discord server, I already created
something called bot fun,
so we don't spam general.
The way the way the Tremor bot works
is if you want to look at the
there's a file called plugins dot yaml, I
believe.
No. It's called discord dot yaml because
obviously.
And in there, have different plugins.
Hold on. Because I used the temporary directory,
I need to get my split into it.
I'm I'm glad I'm glad I'm not the
only one making his own life miserable.
Yes. Okay.
What do we wanna see here?
There's a if you look into config, there's
a zero one Discord YAML.
Presenting? So this is separated from the
from the config because there are no secrets
in here.
And you remember the cookie monster in the
image?
Yes. The pipeline.
There are multiple of those since you are
not limited to a single one.
And
what we have is we have made each
plug in a pipeline that are all connected
here.
So if you look, for example, at line
13 and following,
which doesn't mean that I say 13 because
you have line numbers turned off. But I'm
cheating. I have the file open with line
numbers.
Yeah. You see we have the pipeline no
bot
in there Mhmm. And and the output of
that, and we connect it to the input
of the setup pipeline, the roles pipeline,
the code of conduct pipeline, the inclusivity pipeline,
the welcome pipeline, the jokes pipeline.
Yep. Got it.
And so those are all the plug ins
we have right now.
There
is
the most interesting one to look at is
probably the inclusivity one. That is something we
Robinhooded
from the CNCF discord.
Well, we we are we are just stealing
stuff from all around. Isn't that the CNCF
Slack?
Yeah. The Slack. Yes. Yes. The CNCF Slack.
So so something we really like is if
if someone said, hey, guys, it was like,
well, do you mean something else? Perhaps.
And we wanted that on the Discord server.
So we have a
a plugin for that that does
exactly that.
Okay. So how do we do something with
this Discord bot? Right now, I'm assuming this
Tremor bot is using Tremor and it is
it listening to Discord right now? So if
we start to type things, is it gonna
come into our pipeline and allow us to
to transform? Would you believe there are literally
people trying to interact with your bot right
now you make changes? The demo guys are
horrible too. Why why the hell, I guess
that's not swearing in the bad way, is
it not working in the bot function?
Oh, no. I am. Nobody knows.
Is it? I am Oh, maybe we can
fix it during the live session.
Yes. We can fix it during the live
session.
Also, can just use general and there, at
least Tremor bot replies,
which is a good start. Okay. So if
we type here guys, Tremor bot is gonna
learn how to
type.
I bet it doesn't work with it. Oh,
we we we should teach Tremor bots, dovish,
and maybe Derek as well.
Just why not?
Alright. Alright. Yep. Trips. Okay.
Let's let's throw this guy in. There is
this. There is the Tremor death bot.
Oh, is he in bot fun now? Yeah.
Yeah. Okay. There we go. That's you. Yo.
This is this is your bot.
Okay. Cool. That makes sense. I get it.
So this is all powered with Tremor.
Yeah.
All of that is and you can look
at the code for that to get an
idea how to do something like that.
Is that what's inside of the
lib directory?
So that is inside the config and the
lib directory. There's config plugins, which has the
pipelines, and the lib directory
is additional
helper functions, basically.
Okay. So let's look at this. What
what is it about trickle?
Yeah.
Well,
our naming sort of has a joke
running through us. So because it's Tremor
Everything is so good. All the
the languages that we have will begin with
Steve.
So Trickle is called Trickle from the Days
of Thunder movie
because he feels the need for speed.
The query language is all about processing speed.
So it's sort of a meta joke beginning
with his team. So is the language called
Trekle?
Yes. Yeah. Right. Got it. Perfect. So this
If
you think about it, it makes sense. Most
query languages in this space for real time
are filtering.
So they're dropping a lot of data on
the floor. So you're taking a fire hose
and you're sending a trickle downstream.
Okay. Got it. So let's see if we
can work this out. Let's see how intuitive
this language is.
Yep. I'll I'll let you go over this
before we explain it.
Thanks.
Okay. So we've got a select. So right
away I'm thinking this is the stream processing
function. I'm assuming this is a pattern match
on a field called message.
We're trying to extract
channel ID
and then I'm not sure what's going on
here. Oh, this is the response. Okay. So
Yeah. Yeah. We've got a select on a
message with a channel ID and then we
send
and a response to the original ID, the
contents in, hey, and and I've got some
sort of interpolation
syntax here to inject things in and then
we got the from.
So the from is,
okay, this is where the actual match is
happening and we're looking for where the content
contains the word guys.
Interesting use of stars here, I guess.
It's a block. Yeah.
And then the default is to nothing.
Easy. I think I understood that relatively well.
Tell me what I got wrong. Yeah. You
you got it. So the it's it's sort
of like a SQL language. So Tremor is
the inverse of a database. In a database,
you store the data and you run ad
hoc queries. In an event processing system, you
optimize the query and you throw ad hoc
data through it.
So this is a is SQL like, but
it's not ANSI compliant SQL,
because, like, who it's it's twenty twenty one.
Who uses columnar,
data in modern systems? Most people are using
structured data like JSON, so we just threw
away the columns and tables and we're getting
with the the old structured program.
So we have nested data structures and it
it maps
the business domain events much more closely. So
it makes it more intuitive.
Nice. Okay. Let's take a look at one
more of these, and then we'll maybe see
if we can modify the behavior in some
way. Which one of these is your favorite?
Welcome is fairly easy.
Jokes is absolutely stupid,
and roles is really complex.
Okay. So I guess we'll just look at
them all then.
We've got we've got a select here, same
again. We've got a send message.
This
syntax
here,
are we trying to
alright. Okay. So we're looking for some sort
of event type where the member edition is
is true. Okay. Got it.
Okay. I'm I'm curious.
This is just running straight up Tremor. Right?
Is there a flag of the I could
see the events coming in. Can I print
them to standard out so I could see
what we're You absolutely can? That is a
pipeline.
If you look at the config where at
the zero one Discord one
Yep. Yeah. We'll just modify that, and we'll
add a one of the built in pipelines
will allow you to redirect the standard output
or one of the built in connectors.
We'll just configure that, and you'll see the
events streaming.
Because I imagine if I wanna start adopting
Tremor in my infrastructure for, you know think
a simple use case up front is gonna
be logs and metrics for most people. I
probably want to know what the message is
coming in from the sources look like before
I started to do the transformation.
So Yes. We actually have thought about that.
Line nine.
You see there's this debugging
Yep. In the pipeline pass through, which is
a standard pipeline that always exists, which just
passes through data.
And that means everything that comes in, we
just pass on there. And in line eleven
and twelve, we pass this data to standard
out.
So while you're on commenting, you've just implemented
that. Yeah.
Does it gonna do that content re It
It doesn't auto reload. No. You got to
restart it.
Alright. And not a noise feature. Please raise
an announcement request.
Yeah. If I can send a sec up
to I'm quite a happy person. So
let's get some blank lines in here. Let's
someone's already typing. I'll just wait. Oh, there
we go. Cool.
So we can see coming in here, we've
got the ID, we've got attachments, we've got
the offer avatar.
There's that channel ID that we were plucking
out and the trickle script.
We've got the content.
Guess that's We're
not gonna be able to see a member
edition. That's probably gonna be a little bit
more difficult to trigger on the livestream. But
Yes. Someone will have to join. Well, we
just got to need
to make people join the Tremor server if
they want to see it in here. Okay.
I'm getting it. It's it's starting to make
sense to me now.
It seems like Oh, look. I got not
bad. You're onto a
live Yes. On the on the stream. Yes.
So is it fair to say that this
zero one config,
is this the
is this the most important part of this
configuration? This is where I have It's plumbing
effectively.
It's and this is where we haven't yet
gotten rid of the YAML.
And this makes it a bit hard to
read. There is a RFC on our RFC
sites about implementing
Troy.
Anoop?
That was the name, wasn't it? Yes. Yeah.
Troy. Yeah. Yes. Troy. Which
which hopefully
will
replace the lovely YAML
and with something not as readable and helpful
for developers,
but closer to the other language.
I I I have actually, I'm not familiar
with Troy. I have no idea what that
Neither option really is doesn't exist yet.
Tremor deploy. So it's the Tremor deployment language.
One of the limitations with YAML,
is that we don't have the kind of
tooling we would like to give the kind
of hygienic errors that we would like,
through it as an interface. It becomes cumbersome
to describe.
With the language that understands
a lot of the primitives
in the, scripting language, we could reuse a
lot of that logic and make it a
lot more flexible. So for someone who already
knows the scripting and query language, it would
be more intuitive
not to have to jump into a,
a format like YAML and to just use
the tools they have and build on top
of them.
Okay.
Got it. I'm really glad I never lied
and just said, yeah. Try and put over
that. It's a really cool project. And then
That
would be cool then then you can help
us implement if you know it already. You're
still ahead of us. Awesome. Exactly.
I'll I'll come and comment on an RSE
for sure. Was someone else gonna talk there?
Sorry. I I'm sure I heard another voice.
Oh, yes. I was just gonna comment on
the Tremor CLI actually has a facility to
run your little scripts, like, on its own
too. So you you don't really have to
start the whole thing like how you did
for the Discord case. So you can actually
test, like, individual logic by itself, and that's
actually a really killer feature. So that allows
us to, like, test logic in isolation,
and you can also actually do, like, kind
of, like, unit testing around it or the
Tremor CLI has a test feature. You can
also write, like, full blown, like, integration test
too. So the production logic that you have
running in your, like, servers, you can actually,
like, validate beforehand,
and you can iterate on it really fast.
So that's like a that was a huge
event. That's a huge advantage compared to
the solutions that Tremor was replacing it with
things like Logstash really don't allow you to
do that that way. So that's why, like,
Tremor really soon for us, and it's, invaluable.
But yeah. Okay. There's lots of tools in
that Tremor command line. You can Yeah.
It's got five benchmarking or five testing systems
including the benchmark environment we use.
So you can literally write a directory,
fill it full of integration tests, unit tests,
benchmarks,
and share them with us, and we can
run them.
So that makes it easy to communicate failures
and communicate odd behaviors.
Everything through to if you want to debug
what the interpreter inside Tremor sees, there's a
whole heap of debugging tools that give you
syntax highlighted, lexical forms,
the the tree
the the syntax tree that Tremor generates, all
syntax highlighted,
including syntax highlighted source
on the command line.
So you don't even have to spin up
an IDE if you don't want to.
Okay. So I just wanna make sure I
understood that correctly.
What we're seeing with the Tremor CLI is
actually I can have
maybe, you know, a day, a week, a
month, whatever of JSON or CSV data or
something that then I can run against the
test that my transcripts are doing, what I
actually expect them to do. Yeah. Is that
something where Tremor provides some sort of assertion
framework, or would I bring in something like
conf test on top of that to do
it? So, yes, if you have a look
at the integration tests in the Tremor runtime
repo,
in Tremor Cloud, you'll see a test folder.
In the test folder, you'll see a number
of different, frameworks.
We do everything from
verifying our API works with curl
through to
running integration tests where Tremor is running Docker,
which is running Elastic or
Tremor
is running Tremor. So you can have multiple
Tremor's running in integration tests, and it does
expect some expect style assertions
on that. So,
you're in, tell you wanna go to TremorCly
tests rather than the,
the built in tests. They're more like unit
tests. They are Rust tests.
So TremorCry
tests.
Pick.
Pick one doesn't matter.
So we have a unit testing framework in
the scripting language that,
is like JUnit
or any of the other unit style testing
frameworks. So that works in TremorScript.
So with the standard library, you can look
at the standard library tests.
There's only about 900 of them, so it's
a long file.
Well, this is quite short. Unless I'm in
the wrong file. You've got one with the
other file.
It's also a good file. Quite long.
Where is the long easier. It's easier to
use the short file.
Okay. So what I can see here is
we define some sort of test suite. We
give it a name. The suite itself has
multiple tests. That makes sense. I like the
fact there's tagging here that tells me that
I could probably run a subset of my
tests across multiple files. Yes. Yes. We can.
Which I'm always excited by. It's the simple
things that keep me happy.
And then this individual test itself, which is
also got a name and then we have
a test assertion that the host name is
my system's host name.
Okay. I think that makes sense.
Is Tremor doing any sort of enrichment in
those messages as they come into my system?
The which yes,
but only slightly.
The I think it does well, adds a
few things. It adds a timestamp when the
message arrived.
We
also use the timestamp for sneaky stuff like
random number generators to guarantee determinism.
So if you would replay the same data
with the same timestamps,
you get the same randomness,
which is really powerful if you want to
test your system and figure out why the
hell did this message not arrive if I
configure 50% drop rate.
Because, well, if you comp replay it with
the same same time stamps, off you go,
you get the same results.
Then it
adds some metadata depending on where the data
comes from. For example, if it's a HTTP
request, you get the headers. You get
the HTTP,
the other side, the client information, all that.
So there is some enrichment happening, and that
is usually happening in the metadata.
So if you look at an event, there's
body, the body, the event data, and the
metadata, which is then the data that tells
you something about the event but isn't the
event, if that makes sense.
A little bit.
So in the in the scripting language, we
didn't see it in the
scripts that we were using. But if you
use the dollar sign in the scripting or
query language,
that means you're referencing a meta information. Okay.
That can be generated by the connectors into
the system. So, like, Discord might generate some
meta information.
And some of the plug ins to the
query language,
might actually also generate or consume metadata to
perform their particular functions.
So it's,
Tremor also has an other form of metadata
that isn't exposed
in the languages that it uses for things
like acknowledgments,
guaranteed delivery, circuit breakers,
that are running invisible to the user unless
you're using an operator designed for the user
to interact with those subsystems.
So
Okay. So let's assuming I'm running Tremor on
a bunch of Linux machines on Equinix Metal.
Equinix Metal has a metadata service where I
can fetch some information from. Is that something
that I would do before I run Tremor
and populate a config file with key value
pairs or something? Is that something I would
write a plugin for Tremor for to scrape
or like how how would I interact with
this in that? That's a great question. You
would write that in Tremor,
deploy it with Tremor, and you could do
that live.
I you could literally have a stream of
changes coming through or pull the metadata system
periodically
using the metronome or we have a a
Chrome operator called Chrono. So once per day,
you could download new metadata or every ten
seconds. I mean, you can you can literally
configure this
or code this depending on how you view
the scripting language as you like.
Okay. Can we clarify the difference? Config file
and load it. That's that's okay too.
So can we clarify the difference? Is there
a Tremor language and a Trickle language? Are
those different
things? Yes and no. So the the Trickle
language is is superset of the Tremor language.
So you
there is a scripting language, and you can
embed the scripts inside the query language. So
you and then you will have the Troy
language which you can embed the query language.
It's it's turtles all the way down just
with silly t based names. It's yes.
Turtles. They start with t. Damn it.
We need a higher level language called turtle
now. It's It's turtles
all the way down. So Now the lowest
is an old and turtle.
Yeah. The lowest level is TremorScript,
the scripting language. That
gets wrapped by the query language, which lets
you describe graphs.
Eventually, this gets wrapped. This makes a lot
of sense. There are a lot of programming
languages that have attempts attempted to build low
code or no code flow based languages.
And the problem is when the logic gets
very, very complicated,
it's very difficult to write imperative or procedural
logic
in flow languages.
Just like it's almost impossible to write
flow based logic in imperative languages, like, look
at callback hell in anything from Node. Js
to,
the modern JVM.
Callback hell is indicative of this is a
flow oriented environment or system. You're trying to
describe a stream of connected things in something
not designed
around those structural concerns that are flow oriented.
And you get exactly the same with business
logic or mathematical logic. It doesn't want to
be represented as a graph. It wants to
be represented in something textual
and something more familiar.
So we've just made the choice of let's
use the query language that's flow structured for
flow oriented things, and let's plug in something
a lot more relevant,
to the business logic for what people want
to do with that data as it's flowing
through. And today, that is a very ETL
oriented
language,
designed around slicing and dicing
and processing business
like nest data,
you know, JSON,
which is 99%
of JSONS.
Okay. I'm gonna throw something
out there.
I don't know if that deviates too far
from your plan of what we were gonna
Go ahead throw stuff out.
But we're in a position right now where
we have an applicator we did until I
think. I killed Until you stop. Yeah. So
we can run Tremor,
but we can add new sources to this,
right? Yeah. And those can interact with the
other parts of the pipeline that already exist
right now, which is the ability to write
to your Discord channel.
Yeah. I
can imagine a world where I wanna be
able to be you know, maybe I want
to monitor the CPU and memory on my
machine, and if it reaches a certain threshold,
send a message to a Discord channel. Is
that something we can throw together now or
is that something that yes.
As long as you have.
Is Telegraph the collector? I believe, yes. Isn't
it? It is the collector. Yeah. And so
you can hook up Telegraph to Tremor to
Discord.
No problems. Well, what about if we keep
it really simple? Can we can we monitor
a file with Tremor and if I just
echo something into the end of that file,
can it just relay onto
Tremor does not tail files. You could use
UDP, WebSockets or TCP for that.
Okay. Netcat.
So I can run Telegraph tomorrow to that
file and write it to UDP socket and
then we can Or
vector. Well, or you can just use Or
vector and Netcat. Yes.
Oh, yeah. We could just use Netcat. Let's
try and keep it simple. Let's not bring
in too many tools. So
how okay. What's well, how do we do
that? How do we how do we expose
Tremor to something on my machine that I
can send arbitrary messages to your Discord channel?
Well, the first thing would be adding a
source. Let's add a source. Okay. Let's add
a source. Why do we why do we
Hans, why do we add Blaster and just
configure it to send slash e t c
passwords through to this one?
How about not?
Okay. So let how do I do this?
Well,
let's look at the documentation.
So we we'll flag our documentation.
Docs. Come on. I've got I've got Well,
I can't ever remember what I'm doing.
Literally, I can't remember what I am doing.
I'm always looking at the documentation.
And if you go there into artifacts and
then on ramps, you can see what data
what sources Tremor can
get data from. Okay. So we've identified some
vocabulary there that I wasn't particularly familiar with.
I don't see it in the config, but
I just ignored it for now. So on
ramps are our sources and off ramps are
outputs. Yes.
Our syncs, which is our fault that we
haven't gone through renaming them all to source
and syncs.
But basically, yes. On, it goes there. Off,
it goes out.
Okay. So I see a file on ramp
here. Can we not just use that? Well,
we'll only read a file once.
Got it. Okay. So the the story behind
this is tailing a file is actually a
really complicated thing.
Right? It is it sounds easy,
but it isn't.
And there are the great folks over at
well, now it is where are they now?
David. David.
Right. Yes.
We have project called Vector.
It's really good at
log tailing, and we don't like spending our
time doing log tailing. So we just recommend,
hey. Folk use Vector.
It's awesome. It connects to Tremor. Okay.
So We use it as a sidecar whenever
we need to do log tailing. We just
use that other project.
It's really good at it. So you know?
Okay. Well, I mean, I I'm happy just
to click control c and run Tremor again
after modifying this file because we just want
I just want to show a demo of
of of this. I was like, actually, adding
a new source and then having it work
with one of the syncs.
I think the easiest way is do you
ever use web Socat?
I've used Socat before. Yes.
Well, the the
yeah.
UDP.
The simple UDP on ramp which just uses
this as a message. Okay. So let's click
on UDP. I'm gonna just grab this config
here. Yep.
And we're gonna drop that in to our
config o one discord. Is that right?
Yes.
That was said with some degree of confidence.
Because there is the secret there is the
secret file and I wanted to make sure
you don't open it. So this is gonna
run a UDP server on local host port
9,000 of which I can send JSON to
and it'll do something with it. Nearly. Oh,
probably want to use the line's preprocessor.
You
what you did is put it under binding,
but it is an on ramp. And we
are sadly in YAML and oh, sorry. In
the wonderful world of YAML,
where
you got to put it under
the on ramp top level thing.
Just create a section.
Yeah. The the section was on ramps. That's
why I hesitated. It's in this hidden file,
but you can define one here as well.
Alright. Okay. So can I just do on
ramps? Yep. Yeah. You can. Okay. Singular.
It's on them. Got it.
Yeah. Okay. So that's You also could have
been really lazy and copied it from the
example completely because it's already in there.
Okay. So I can save this now and
I guess as a UDP socket, we can
send a message. You haven't looked at hooked
it up to anything yet.
That's a good point. Okay. So I I
guess this is what the bindings are. Do
we have to buy something
from our on ramps to our from our
sources to our sync?
Okay. Yeah.
So is that just a case of saying
ID and I'll just say
Rawkode.
I'm assuming that's arbitrary.
We wanna create a Yep. I'm just gonna
keep making this up until someone tells me
I need to do something else.
Well, you're now connecting the Discord on the
RAM, not the UDP one.
Okay. So I need to use the ID
from above, which I called UDP.
Okay.
Is that arbitrary as well or is that
actually connected to the oh, the type is
this one? That's connected to the ID that
you're
Yeah. You could you could call it snot
better if you wanted to.
Okay. So now that we've got this out
link, we tell it which inputs to forward
on. Is that right?
Which to which input to forward it. Yes.
Which the pass through one is the simplest
one.
Okay. Let me just copy that so I
don't mess that up. Exactly. Be be lazy
and just copy the debugging one.
Is that it?
Nearly.
Nearly? What what The last part is the
mapping at the very bottom.
Since you made a new binding, you have
to tell Tremor to load it.
Okay. So binding
UDP
You call it Rawkode. Rawkode.
No. Rawkode on the you call the binding
Rawkode.
When you put ID in the binding,
Rawkode slash o one. I wanna see what
I did there. Oh, yeah. Okay. So this
is this pending here. Yeah.
Okay. So binding Rawkode o one, and is
that just I I don't know what the
first. That is. That works. That'll work.
And now you should see UDP messages going
there to your standard out.
So I can just do a make run
and it's not gonna blow up. Right? Well,
we'll see.
Okay. So now we have I don't trust
live coding anymore. After the start today,
it didn't. Okay.
So
I wonder if we could to an off
run.
Yeah. I think it just went to the
pipeline only, right, so far? It it it
went to the pipeline.
It's
let's connect. That's a different binding.
It's a different binding, so it will not
Oh, wow. This is this now I'm learning
something. That works? Bash provides a virtual networking
stack, and I can't I
don't know if this will is that the
right port number? It's 9,000.
Yep. It's 9,000. Yeah. I think so. So
that's not quite right. Definitely something like this.
Oh, I'm not running bash.
That could could be a reason.
Yeah.
I used to use this all the time,
but there's like a virtual networking stack and
I'm sure I'm gonna get it slightly wrong
and need to Google it.
But it's something like this.
Oh, it didn't work. Alright. You could use
Netcat.
I know, but now that I now now
I feel I need to teach you this
thing. Okay. That's fair. That we have learned
something?
We're gonna have to upgrade the bash from
the ZSH.
Bash. I'm not going back to bash. I
am sorry. I like z s h to
bash. But it's an upgrade. It's it's UDP
capable with virtual UDP. What's not to like?
So I used to use this in my
health checks and my Docker containers.
Dev TCP, that must be it. Dev TCP
I'm
I'm 50% of all the Solaris users. I
I want
no bash. I want all my scripts to
be good old shell. There. I was close.
It's not net, it's just dev UDP.
That should have sent a lot to that
UDP channel. Well, yes. But you're told that
it's Chase.
Oh, string is That's a JSON string.
Oh, it's not like.
Yeah.
Okay.
Let's see if that works.
Didn't.
Okay. So maybe that's just my crappy bastric.
So why don't we just try it your
way? No. No. Well, then then then it's
my fault suddenly. It would be net cat
minus u local host 9,000 and then you
can write.
Pass n c dash u.
That.
Nope. Maybe space.
Okay.
And now I just need the JSON payload.
Nope. It wasn't wasn't your UDP.
Okay. So there's something wrong with connect to
because it's sent to the pass through end.
Yes.
Let's see what pass through end is connected
to in the
Discord YAML.
Okay. So let me just drop out of
that pop open a Discord YAML.
So okay. So we got the binding, we've
got on ramp UDP, out system
pass through. And what's pass through in connected
to on our links?
It's in Discord. It's connected to standard out.
No. It's it's a different one because it's
a
should should should be a different one.
No. It should be the same. Gonna be
zero one. They're all mapped to zero one
for I.
Okay.
So where is in
sorry.
Yeah. I've pipeline system pass through, I was
just connected to all from standard out in.
That's not what we want. We
wanted to it's going out of Discord. So
we wanna connect it to the Discord off
ramp. Well, we wanted to first go out
to standard out to just test.
Alright. Let's do that then.
So that should already
print on standard out?
It should. Yes. Which is annoying that it
doesn't. Think it's when it doesn't.
Mine's prepostor maybe and throw in slash n.
Doesn't
echo put a slash n at the end
of it? Could could be.
So use the lines preprocessor. It's probably just
buffered in UDP going, yeah. Yeah. I don't
know how to send it yet. Is it
finished?
Okay. So what do we want to try?
The lines speed processor.
I could be wrong.
Could be wrong.
On ramp UDP is perfectly fine.
Links is on ramp UDP. Yeah.
But preprocessor, is it it's a good idea.
So in your UDP configuration
Yep. At the same level as config
or just below codecs, preprocessors,
colon,
return
list
or dash
sorry. Dash as in list item and Yep.
So give that a whirl.
Okay. I'm gonna try my bastric again then.
Nope. Let's try the Netcat one.
Well, the bastric wasn't JSON.
Oh, yeah. We could we could make a
codec as string if that doesn't work.
Codec
string is
a safe one. Yeah. Do do
we need to specify, like, the the route,
the pipeline to the upfront explicitly in in
the binding? Because it's part of different binding.
Right? I think so. I think so. Yeah.
I think that's why it's not working.
If we had made it
yeah. If we had reused it on an
existing binding,
then it should have worked. But since this
is a new binding called Rawkode,
the the pass through pipeline isn't connected to
anything in that binding. So I think we
need to, like, explicitly copy the off ramp
part from the second phase to the first
phase.
So maybe that will work worth trying. Yeah.
I hope that made sense, Rawkode. But, yeah,
I I can write you. And this is
why we want to get rid of this
YAML.
Oh, yes.
What do we have to copy into where?
So copy the pass through,
out The scroll down. To Discord from the
Discord binding into the Rawkode binding
so that you have a full copy of
the flow that you want in Rawkode.
Think of Rawkode as a separate application.
Not quite a one to one mapping, but
for live coding, that'll do.
Okay. So so we want to copy the
pasture from here.
Yeah. So copy the
below
one, the out. So the output from the
pass through pipeline, we want to pass in
To yeah. To the old front. Yeah. For
standard out. So this line, we wanna copy
and add to Rawkode.
Okay. So those two lines. Right?
Yeah. I think it's one line. Two lines.
Or is it one or two? Who knows?
Could be one. Should be two lines if
there's no wrapping setup.
Like that? Yes. Yep. Like that. Yep.
Still don't know if it's one or two
lines, but that works.
I should have changed the codec to string
as well, but oh, well. Oh,
one thing at a time.
That's string, son, not Jason.
Yes. I don't think that did that for
me there. I think I've broken it.
Missing a colon between name and value.
You know what? I'm changing this one thing.
Right? Okay. So you're telling me I can
just string as a codec and it doesn't
care what I pass through. Is that right?
Yeah. Exactly. Yeah. String will just do
everything you want. Let's remove as as much
things that can go wrong in my typing
as possible. So hello.
I'll go.
No. That didn't work.
That is
super So
we have a UDP on ramp.
And we I mean, although should we set
it because if it's UDP, we're not actually
gonna know if it fails because there's no
response. Should we use TCP instead? Yeah. Give
it a shot.
Give give it a shot. And you can
keep it named UDP. It won't if you
change the ID, you don't need to change
the IP.
Okay.
It'll be confusing later when you've forgotten why
you did it. Okay.
So there's there's some buffering
or something.
But then I I need to know if
this works. So
See, there So now we can change it
back to Jason if you like,
or we can configure it and send it
out to Discord.
I think it is configured to go to
Discord, does it not?
It's configured to go to system out.
You may need to copy that
as well. Okay. So let's add our our
final mapping here just to
Or we could just move the
the The standard out one? Our TCP UDP.
The
second line of links
to our discord and get rid of the
binding and the mapping.
Move it all into the same
discord binding.
Keep it simple.
Get rid of the other lines. Yeah. Because
we just need the UDP,
and that will union into the password.
But can I just do that and remove
this?
That removes the rest of the block functionality.
You can do that.
But that will ring it to Discord. Right?
It will Discord will tell you this is
not a message I understand unless you give
it the correct
format. Structural leads. Which is where all the
selects are in.
But we can just copy one of those
and we can make one and just add
another pipeline.
Okay. I'll let you just gave me. What
what what do we do to make this
work?
Let's create a pipeline
and just give it a give it a
random name. Just just pick a name you
want for your pipeline.
Okay. And that's the stuff that's in the
lib directory. Is that right? No.
That's in the plugins directory.
Config.
Oh, contact plugin. Yeah. Call it the Rawkode
plugin. Okay. So we're gonna go to config
plugin. We're gonna copy the simplest one with
the welcome, wasn't it?
It's the welcome. Yes. Okay. And we'll call
this Rawkode dot trickle.
Okay. So now we can do a select.
Now we're not reading messages from this card,
so this is gonna be different. Right?
And you know, so this part of the
select creates
the message that's outgoing. It's like like, okay.
Think about select. If you select
host name from table,
then what is between select and from is
the data that goes out.
Yeah. So just get rid of the content
value
and replace it with event, which represents what
you've passed in and what is sent through
TCP.
So hello is what you typed the last
time. So that would be the string.
Was the text? For event, and it's hash
rather than dollar for interpolation.
There you go. A smiley.
There. I'm happy. So if you put a
small e for event, it's case sensitive
with the variables. There we go. Perfect. One
one last thing, the channel ID, since that
isn't the welcome channel,
and
this is Discord specific, that would be that
number.
Yes. Did you send it over to
Yes. I sent it over Discord. You don't
want that all to go to the welcome
channel. That's where we have the bot spam
channel. Yeah. I just have to move that
to the other screen so that we can
flash the Goddamn your screens.
The secret.
Okay.
So let's get back. So I copied that
ID
and then like so.
And number, not string. Just just the number.
Got it.
I believe. I believe to believe. We'll find
out. We'll find out in a second. Okay.
So now we've got our match here, and
I guess the
well, what do we have to change care
about that. We're just just true.
Just yeah. Just remove the whole where. Else.
Just remove the whole thing
because we don't care. Yep. Bang it on.
Send it on. Everything is fine.
This will actually not work because event isn't
true. Just
kill kill the whole line, make it default
true. Got it.
This is this is the most powerful message
statement ever.
Yeah.
Is that all we need in our trickle?
Yeah. That's it. I believe it is. That's
an entire program right there. Okay. So now
how do we connect this to Rawkode. Trickle
from our config? So if you the the
way the bot works, it it loads all
the plugins.
So you now have a plugin on Rawkode
effectively.
Yeah.
You don't need to put it in there.
Rawkode will be your plugin. So you just
make a new line
and you connect the outputs
of
Basically, instead of systems, standard out. First link.
That's alright. Can send it to standard out
and
add a new list element that sends it
to slash pipeline
slash Rawkode,
squiggly eyes, squiggly slash in,
as well as standard apps. So you'll see
it on the console,
and you'll also get it sent. So online
number one up from where you are.
It goes into the slides. If you go
to the end of this line and make
a new list entry
Yep. It's called quote slash pipeline
because it's a it's a pipeline or flow
slash Rawkode
because it's Rawkode dot trickle that takes the
file name base Yep. And it uses that.
And slash,
because it's this instance,
you're gonna go squiggly eye squiggly.
And slash in because it's going to the
standard input stream on that file. So we
didn't cover a lot of the details. You
can configure your own streams and stuff, but
this will work.
Yeah. So it's all gonna be
Well, we also need to put the output
somewhere. We need the output. Yeah. It'll almost
work. On Now we need to do something
know the line. No. This would be the
UDP output.
So
you change the UDP output to go to
Discord output. That should go to the system
pipeline path throughout.
No.
Line numbers. Line number plus one.
Yes.
What's the option? Increment the line numbers. I
forgot.
Did that turn out? N u. N u.
That's what it is. There we go.
Yeah.
And then after line number 18,
and now we have the Rawkode pipeline, and
we have slash pipeline Rawkode I out. So
we connect the outside of that.
So that's the the result of your select
statement, which is your
message event into Discord.
Okay. So slash pipeline slash Rawkode.
Slash squiggly eyes squiggly slash out.
Squiggly eyes squiggly. That'd be a good pirate
name.
Oh, yes. Squiggly eyes squiggly. Squiggly eyes squiggly.
And we connect that to the
and now it gets confusing. In ramp, on
ramp, Discord, I squiggly, I out.
So we we loop back effectively.
Okay. That's actually making much more sense to
me now that we've walked through this. So
that's good. Just seems to be a list.
It's it's easier to type when you're not
trying to say it at the same time
across the Internet.
Yes.
Alright. I'm confident. No. I'm not. I'm in
the wrong direction.
There you go.
Okay. Discord send message to LAR.
Yeah. Because it it's it's trying to send,
I think, this message as
because we connected to this standards.
Oh, you could the past yes. It will
it Did
we make an infinite loop?
Really?
I think if you UDP to it, you
should see it.
TCP to it. Sorry. That's okay. Into that
port. Let's have some fun.
Nice.
Tada. Well, we are we are getting some
stuff.
The debug no. But we are getting
well, we are getting the output from
the debug. You have the debug still just
enabled, so it sends all the debug messages
to
Discord.
Since I'm not sure there's something sensitive in
there, I will delete this. Yeah. I'm pleased
to.
So if I just take off the standard
oh,
this one. Right?
If you just go to line plus two
plus three, and instead of connecting 17,
instead of connecting this to pass through, just
connect that to your Rawkode pipeline
without the system. System
notates a pipeline that is always there. You
don't have to define the pass through pipeline
because it always exists.
Two colon colon slash. Yes. And
there you go. Yeah.
I didn't even notice when we typed in
system colon colon Rawkode. Where did we add
that Rawkode
sub module to the standard
Oh. System.
Still some stuff there. You know what? I'm
fine if you just delete that. I I
got I we did what I wanted to
see and I'm very chuffed with that. But
I love that.
So we have the ability with Tremor to
add our sources
and basically build all of these workflows or
pipelines up that allows us to move those
messages about the filtering on them and what's
the other stuff. That I think is very
very cool. If you if you would look
at the
script, the Rawkode pipeline you wrote, this could
be if it were, like,
influx data, you could say if CPU users
is over 15%, send the message, oh my
god. It's burning.
Yeah. So you could use this for alerting
into Discord or Slack or whatever.
Yeah. And we're just doing that in this
this match statement down here. Like, we can
have the different cases an alarm if it
goes over a certain value. And if you've
seen this alarm trigger before, don't alarm continuously.
Only alarm once for the given condition.
So there is a state mechanism in Tremor,
so you could,
cash this in the state mechanism. And if
the alarm is set,
don't retrigger the alarm if it's already going
off. It's annoying.
And then when it's recovered at some point
later, maybe send it again.
But you can Tremor is quite flexible
in terms of its mechanism. There's a hindsight
of the mechanism recently
that provides a a key value storage,
as,
essentially
sources and syncs.
So you can you can store persistent key
value information now and and just make it
available like it's a service
into that logic.
Makes it really easy to build stateful apps
just by programming little select statements.
Yep. Nice.
Awesome.
So we're we're pretty much approaching an hour
and a half now, which is our our
allocated time. Is there anything that we haven't
shown that you wanted to show before we
finish up today?
I think it's actually pretty nice what we
actually,
other than the stuff that didn't work.
Everything worked. This is what you're talking about.
Yes. Everything worked. It worked perfectly. I think
the messages are all gone.
Other than Rawkode says help me,
that's still there.
Okay. So can we just touch on one
thing if you if you've all got a
few more minutes before we finish? We mentioned
that at the start something that really piqued
my my interest, and we talked about clustering.
Can we cover what how that works,
the status of that is, and what's coming
maybe? I think that is another topic. The
stage is yours.
Yeah.
Sure. So so far, like, as you can
see, so you can run, like, Tremor on
your individual host, and you can imagine, like,
having different Tremor notes running on different hosts.
Right? And with something like Kafka,
you can kind of try to have, like,
a clustered kind of scenario. But, yeah, we
have noticed that for operational needs at Wake,
it would be really nice if we could
deploy these kind of pipelines
in a true, like, distributed system. So imagine,
like, nodes Tremor nodes going down, and then
your pipeline, like, recovering automatically, like, the the
workload is migrated to some other existing node
transparently by the cluster, and the operator doesn't
have to intervene. So it's not just the
the pipeline redundancy.
So there are, like, certain logic that you
write as part of your, like, clustered application.
So think about, like, when you need to
throttle, like, incoming logs or, like, metrics
over, like, a set of notes, and then
you have to really know, like, how many
set of notes are involved to evenly throttle
among all the notes. So things like that,
we hope to provide by introducing a true
clustered system in Tremor. So we are using
draft as the consensus mechanism
for the backbone of the cluster, and the
actual, like,
workload for the Tremor nodes, the pipeline stuff
that you have been playing around, they'll actually
live outside of the draft context.
We call them, like, worker nodes,
and they will be, like, hosting
the the all the processing logic. And whenever
a node goes down or off, ultimately, we
want to reach to that idle state of
the cluster being, like, auto healing. And, ultimately,
those kind of things will also help, like,
auto scale the cluster nicely. You you add
a new node, and then you really don't
have to do much. Right now, there's, like,
a lot of operational
overhead and a lot of config tweaking when
you when you add one. So so that's
where, like, that's kind of the motivation behind
adding clustering. So imagine, like, Tremor being, like,
a true distributed system.
And you you will still have the current
option of running Tremor without
without the distributed context because, honestly, like, the
district adding distributed mechanics like that includes, like,
certain workflows, but it it is, like
the dis a distributed system can be, like,
a lot more painful to manage,
right, compared to, like, a totally, like, a
stateless and system
that we have right now. So there's, like,
a trade after, but we hope, like, the
for the workflows,
it's going to improve. It will be worth
it, and the other option will always be
available in Tremor anyways. So, yeah, that's kind
of the summary
for, like, the team we're trying introduce. So
it'll be like you'll be able to write
a select statement that contains your JSON like
data, but it's distributed now. So you if
if you want to start little bits of
SQL and little bits of JSON, you can
call yourself a distributed systems programmer and get
the big bucks,
just by running a SQL query. So that's
pretty cool.
It's cool trickle right there.
Yeah. You can you can write, like, the
studio applications in Tremor now. So after this
is done. Oh, we're gonna have to have
another episode. I think that's that's for sure.
Until
we are there, it will take a while.
Yeah. Surprisingly, distributed systems are not implemented overnight.
Tell a lot of my So this work
is ongoing.
It'll likely be the simple
the simple
the simpler infrastructure for clustering will get out
first in a in a release over the
next few months.
We are gonna go all the way towards
fully automated, fully migrating,
full distributed applications on Tremor,
probably towards the end of this year before
a lot of that comes out
because we're we're gonna test it to absolute
destruction
before we put any of those features into
anywhere near a release. I'm assuming Because at
the end of the day, we're a production
project. So
we run very close to production.
And most pretty much every feature in Tremor,
even the Discord bot runs in production.
So
every feature in there is a production feature.
So we're we play it safe when it
comes to Yep. The logic.
Must have been that's coming in the pony
rewrite. Right? Tremor to Retina Pony.
That's Tremor then. Rawkode, how are you with
the pony rewrite of everything?
Yes. It The first ninety percent are done.
Does Poly do Cindy Jason yet?
Yeah. Well, they say I want to know
this. Yeah. It it doesn't need to. Doesn't
need to. It's slow enough without it.
Alright. I'm
gonna let you skip back to your day.
That was a really interesting. I think we
had a lot of fun there. This is
definitely the most fun I've had on our
stream. So I'm gonna thank you all for
for bringing
just
such a cool demo to play with Discord
and make it really visual and interactive for
people that are watching and for bringing the
cookie monster. I'll never say no to having
more cookie monster in the streams. So again,
thank you very much.
You very much. Really cool technology. I'm looking
forward to playing with it more. Have a
great day and I'll speak to you also.
Yeah. Thank you very much. Awesome. Thank you
for having us. Thank you very much. Bye.